to forgive
Satan. Is this wish acceptable? If not,
then what the promise that God gives us
that he will accept any dua?
The question posed by Sarah is that if
Allah is going to accept every dua, he's
given the promise. So if you do good
deeds and you tell Allah to forgive,
will he forgive? If he doesn't, then
Allah hasn't kept his promise. Point
number one, nowhere does Allah anywhere
in the Quran or any authentic hadith
says that he will accept all your it is
your wrong concept. It's a misconception
that you have. What Allah says that if
you truly repent and Allah will forgive
any sin of yours. So however much big
sin you do, as long as you repent
sincerely with your heart, Allah will
forgive you. So that's the reason
if
a person he truly repents he ask for
forgiveness stop what he's doing again
it is wrong never does it again Allah
will surely forgive him but your
question is that if I do good deeds and
I ask Allah to forgive
nowhere does Allah say that Allah will
fulfill all the duas if truly repented
if would have repented to Allah and very
sorry you never did again inshallah
Allah will forgive but Allah knows
everything do that you know that so
where is the question and you saying
that you do the deeds when you ask Allah
to forgive you now where does Allah say
that you going to accept all your duas
Allah will forgive your sin if you truly
repent and you compensate Allah for you
but that doesn't mean that you do some
good deed and you ask Allah to forgive
you please this is not live anywhere and
this is a misconception.